in France president Emmanuel macron laid
a white rose at the monument in
Strasbourg Friday for the four people
killed in this week's Christmas market
attack
it comes as macron ordered stepped-up
security including police in riot gear
to stand guard in Paris as
anti-government protesters are back on
the march it's the fifth consecutive
weekend yellow vest demonstrators are
venting concerns about the economic
inequality and overall anger with the
government Roxana Saberi is in Paris
this morning Roxana good morning good
morning there is a heavy police presence
here at the Arc de Triomphe and across
the city as security forces tried to
prevent a repeat of the violence seen in
Paris the past few weekends today there
have been minor scuffles between
protesters and the roughly eight
thousand police officers deployed in
Paris so far they outnumber the
protesters Paris's Police Department
says around 1,000 demonstrators are in
the streets of Paris this morning
significantly fewer than in previous
weeks when some protesters set cars and
barricades on fire and vandalized luxury
stores police used tear gas and rubber
bullets to control the crowds the
so-called yellow vest demonstrations
named after the safety vest drivers
keeping their cars began in November
across the country to protest against an
increase in fuel taxes but the rallies
morphed into a movement against the high
cost of living in France with some
protesters calling on French president
Emmanuel macron to resign on Monday the
president tried to quell the
demonstrations by promising to raise the
minimum wage and by offering some tax
breaks
he has also cancelled the fuel tax
increase president macro made some
promises on Monday why are you still
protesting because there like one
tense of what the French people are
asking so far a few dozen arrests have
been reported in Paris it's not yet
clear why the numbers of protesters are
so much lower this weekend it could be
because of President McCrone s
concessions the deadly attack in
Strasbourg earlier this week or the
frigid temperatures Michelle Roxana
Saberi thank you